We all know that tools like ChatGPT have really empowered developers to tackle bigger problems.
Are you using Tailwind CSS and need a login page?
Try asking Chat, what is the HTML for a login page with the login, username, password, and a button in its own section in the center of a page?
It will literally give you the first pass version of it.
But how far can we push this?
Fred Tubirant may have taken it farther than most.
He built a functioning SaaS product with paying customers by using only ChatGPT and Python.
It's fascinating to hear his story and see what he's built.
This is Talk Python to Me, episode 459, recorded February 19th, 2024.
Are you ready for your host?
Here he is.
You're listening to Michael Kennedy on Talk Python to Me.
Live from Portland, Oregon, and this segment was made with Python.
Welcome to Talk Python to Me, a weekly podcast on Python.
This is your host, Michael Kennedy.
Follow me on Mastodon, where I'm @mkennedy, and follow the podcast using @talkpython, both on Bostodon.org.
Keep up with the show and listen to over seven years of past episodes at talkpython.fm.
We've started streaming most of our episodes live on YouTube.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel over at talkpython.fm/youtube to get notified about upcoming shows and be part of that episode.
This episode is sponsored by Mailtrap, an email delivery platform that developers love.
Try for free at Mailtrap.io.
And it's brought to you by us over at Talk Python Training.
Did you know that we have over 250 hours of Python courses?
Yeah, that's right.
Check them out at talkpython.fm/courses.
Fred, welcome to Talk Python to Me.
So great to be here.
Thank you so much for the invitation.
Nice to be here.
It's lovely to have you.
We're going to have a lot of fun talking about this app that you've built using highly powered by AI and in different ways.
It's both powered by AI, but also largely built with AI.
And I think it's going to give people an interesting look into what is possible these days.
What is possible?
And the journey of a middle-aged coder or so, maybe.
That's really an interesting thing to discuss.
And maybe we could just start a little bit with the introduction about yourself and then talk a bit about that.
So before we dive into talking about how you use ChatGPT to largely build this app that is a SaaS product service on the internet people subscribe to, which is the dream of many people.
It's awesome.
With AI, just tell people a bit about yourself and then I want to talk about this journey.
It's a long story because I'm turning 50 in June 2024.
So if you listen to this before June 2024, I will be 49.
After, I will be 50.
So, yes, that will be...
You're a spring chicken.
I'm older than you, Fred.
Oh, you're older than me.
Okay, cool.
I found someone older than me to talk to.
Oh, that's fine.
You can still write code into your 50s.
Let me tell you.
The keyboard still works.
It's amazing.
And I started when I was 48.
But maybe we'll get back to this later.
So originally, my professional journey started as an interpreter, Russian, English to French.
So I graduated as an interpreter, so in languages.
And then I started being involved in music.
I was head of sponsorship for a big music festival in Belgium.
I had rock venues, live music venues for a few years.
And then I started being involved in tech as head of product, head of paid acquisition for a few startups.
I had my own startups.
I exited one startup in the fintech space in the early 2000s.
I had a circus for two years.
That's quite...
A circus?
That's quite an interesting story.
Yes, family circus with four big tents, eight tons of equipment.
So that was quite a story.
Was this like Cirque du Soleil or was it with animals or what kind of...
It was more like, I would say, like Cirque du Soleil, but at a smaller, smaller scale, of course.
Okay.
But four tents and circus artists and actors and musicians.
And that was an original show, an original story.
I also produced rock bands.
Maybe I can give a shout out to one of the bands that I love, that I contributed to, the Boxer Rebellion.
Maybe you heard about them, the Boxer Rebellion.
Yeah.
It's a British band based here in London, but with a singer from Nashville, Tennessee, Nathan Nicholson.
So I was involved in music, in tech, I mean, in all of those things.
And I think the project that we're going to talk about is kind of a good mix between music, tech and all my passions.
I was also a radio DJ for you.
So that's why.
That's the audio side, right?
That kind of brings you something together in the music, I suppose, as well.
Exactly.
Amazing.
You know, listening to the story, first of all, what a diverse set of experiences.
That must have been really fun.
It's not a career.
That's the problem.
Unemployable.
Yeah, that's.
But in terms of thinking about products and coding, I know when I experience different areas, I always feel like, oh, this could be way better and that could be way better.
And why is that so hard?
Surely we could create some software to fix these things.
You must have had a lot of ideas about programs you would like to see and stuff you'd like to work on.
And multiple times, the solution for me was to hire people to do it.
I had my own startups in the past and I always had a team of, let's say, two to five developers working for me when we were doing that.
So I kind of understood all the structure, the architecture of the apps, but I'd never really coded myself.
So I was always relying on other people.
The difference today is that I spent most of my days coding, which is quite different.
Yeah. And you said you started coding when you were 48.
Yes.
Roughly almost two years ago.
That's awesome.
You know, I do hear from a lot of people or see comments like, oh, I think I'm too old to learn this or, oh, you can never, you have to have done this when you were a kid or maybe gotten a degree in college.
Otherwise you're doomed.
You know, you surely have an alternative viewpoint on that, given your success.
I thought it would be like that also for me because I would say I'm quite a perfectionist.
So if I learn something, I want to achieve something with what I learn.
And the problem, the issue with code for me for a long time had been that I could go through the basic tutorials, the first lessons, you know, watching some videos or reading some tutorials.
It was difficult for me to really achieve something meaningful, something that I could really share that could become a product because you always end up doing the same little exercises and little tutorials.
And that doesn't end up anywhere.
You learned how to do a loop, but then that doesn't really help you get any closer to an app, right?
How to do a little to-do list or a little calculator or, you know, something very simple, nothing that would be worth sharing as a product and especially as a paid product.
So I always thought, OK, if I want to build a SaaS, the only solution for me is to rely on a freelancer or on an agency or on a team of people.
I was doing it until I discovered it.
That's a big risk.
And it's also not that easy to hire a team to build your product when you're still trying to figure out what a product is and all these things, right?
Even if you hire non-expensive developers, it has still a cost.
And if you want to, you know, just if you don't want to take too much risk and if you want to test your product to see if you have product market fits, I mean, you don't want to spend $5,000, $10,000, $15,000 on a product.
It's difficult.
And the alternative that people are most of the time advocating these days is no code.
So it's building stuff with, let's say, Bubble, which is pretty popular.
You've got Retool.
They've been a sponsor of the show before.
Retool, obviously.
That's pretty nice, but mostly for internal apps.
And also, you can just connect stuff through Zapier, through Make, formerly Integromat.
You can achieve something, but you don't have the control on the UI.
You don't really have the control exactly on what's happening behind the scenes.
And you don't have the flexibility that you have if you really code yourself.
So if you can really get your hands dirty and code on your own.
So I use also to be a strong advocate of no code.
So I'm still using, firstly, Zapier, and then later on, Make.
But once I discovered Python in August, September 2022, then everything changed for me.
Because then I could really start doing my own stuff.
And I started with the back-end stuff, with the back-end scripts, let's say, to create competitive intelligence scripts, things like that.
And I slowly moved into front-end.
But first, for a few months, it was mostly local scripts on my computer.
That's really interesting.
The low-code, no-code stuff is super powerful.
I think it does make it possible for people to build apps.
I have a friend who built a platform a little bit on top of something that's kind of a low-code thing.
And what they're doing is really impressive.
And they've got lots of customers, and it's going really well.
It's a vibrant business.
It's always you're beholden to whatever that platform does.
If the platform has downtime, you have downtime.
If they're changing their feature set in a way that doesn't quite line up with what you're trying to do,
well, that's too bad because they've changed their direction or whatever.
And it's really powerful, but it's also a little bit of a risk, right, to be built on top of that.
A risk, yes.
But for me, it was even more, I would say, the arbitrage was even more about flexibility.
So when you code something on your own with Python, JavaScript, as I'm doing now, it's faster in many cases than trying to figure out how to connect, let's say, Airtable with something else.
And then you've got to think about how the data is structured in Airtable, how the data is to be structured on the other side, and then how to connect them together.
Sometimes it's easier if you just have a SQLite database or MySQL database.
And then if you do your own stuff on your own without trying to connect existing SaaS together.
It was more about flexibility for me, the main reason why I switched almost completely from no code to coding.
That's really interesting.
I guess one more that would be worth considering is price.
Some of these low-code, no-code platforms are really powerful.
But when you start to look at price for a decent number of users using your app, a lot of them are built for internal use cases.
They're not really built for having a bunch of multi-tenant style users and so on.
But also, they can just get real expensive real quick.
Yes, because they are based usually on the amount of transactions or scenarios or zaps that can run.
So if you want to transfer one piece of data from one software to another one, it's one transaction.
If you have, let's say, 10,000 transactions per month for a certain price, then you can run out of transactions pretty quickly.
And very quickly, you end up paying $25, $30, $40 for a pretty low amount of transactions, API calls basically, between the different SaaS.
And if you glue them together, one tool connects to another, which connects to another, then you've got to pay for kind of the traffic and the activity in all three.
It's not just like, well, I'm talking to my database.
I'm now talking to some other service that's got something going on.
And the fact is also that there are a few tools that enable you to create a UI user interface for your product.
But you're limited to the building blocks usually that they offer, even if you can tweak them with some code.
And it's a bit the same.
I would say it's really also the same issue that I've experienced on WordPress, let's say.
The problem is that if you use something like Bubble and you want to build something with it,
you bring to your app all the mothership, the core of the big app, of Bubble as a whole, when you want to build something on top of a platform like that.
It's a lot of things that you don't really need for your specific apps, but that have to be there because the whole engine has to run.
That's usually what you also experience with WordPress, for instance.
When you have a site on WordPress, maybe sometimes or even most of the time, you don't need that big engine.
You could work with a static website with a few HTML, CSS, JavaScript pages.
That would be much lighter.
There would be less code to activate to have your website up and running.
So in terms of performance, if you can code your own stuff, I think it's also a good reason to choose coding versus no code if you can do it.
Totally agree.
Price, performance, control, all those things.
That said, you do have to understand more about the world.
Like one thing we were coordinating around is just like understanding web app architecture.
I don't know how you feel about it, but I feel like a lot of the guidance that is out there is too intense.
There's too many moving parts.
Everyone thinks you need to have some kind of background worker service like Celery, and you need a caching layer,
and you need this and you need that.
And it just starts to be like, whoa, this is like running Netflix.
You know what I mean?
Whereas a lot of times what you need is a back end, a front end and some kind of data store.
And that's it.
And that data store, you mentioned it before, the data store can be in the early days could be SQLite,
which doesn't require another server or another thing to maintain and connect and secure.
And it can just be a file that you back up.
Exactly.
While you're proving out the idea, right?
So maybe you're coming from a place where you weren't a DevOps expert.
You know, like how did this transition go for you?
When I started developing an app, for some reason, I came across Flask as a solution for Python.
So I started developing the app on Flask.
And what I like about Flask is that if you compare it, let's say you use Flask,
and then for the pages, you use HTML, CSS and Vanilla JavaScript.
What I like is that you can deploy an app which comes from a single folder and you've got everything there,
your main Flask file and then all the, let's say the sub files in Python with all the business logic
that you can isolate in one file or another.
It's one project.
And then you deploy the project to GitHub.
And then let's say you connect GitHub to Railway.
I'm using Railway for my deployment.
So you connect GitHub to Railway.
And then once you update your code in PyCharm or in Visual Studio,
then you have the automatic deployment to Railway.
But it's one project.
If you want to decouple completely the backend from the front end,
let's say you work with something like Next.js, for instance,
and then you want to have a backend in something else,
then you've got to have multiple instances and connect them together.
It becomes more complicated.
But if you want to create something simple,
you can keep it simple with one single Flask web app.
And that's what I've been doing so far.
Most of the iJingle maker that I built,
that I've been building since September 23,
is a Flask web app.
So it's one project, one big project.
It's one project.
It's interesting that you mentioned, Cilary, a few moments ago,
because I'm about to ship a new app,
which is coming in the next two weeks or three weeks, I think.
And that's the first time after almost 18 months of development
that I've considered using something like that
because I needed it for performance reasons to process something.
Something you want to start off in the background
and get back and just let it be done later, right?
Yeah.
And it was not that easy.
We had a discussion with someone who is amazing
on the Discord of Railway two or three days ago
because if you're deploying things on Railway,
you would usually use,
that's what they advise you to do as on Heroku,
a proc file.
And the proc file, you've got the start commands
that will start your project.
But on Heroku, which is a competitor of Railway,
you can start both the web app and the worker in the same file.
But you can't do that on Railway.
You've got theoretically to have two different projects,
which kind of defeats the purpose.
You kind of deploy them both, right?
But then you get to more coordination.
Yeah.
But fortunately, and there is a discussion on the Discord
between me and one of their guys there,
they had a way to create a custom JSON for me,
which managed to start both the web app and the worker
in the same deployment.
But I had to fight, to be honest with you,
for like four or five hours to find a solution.
Because sometimes the problem,
and that's the issue that I've seen a lot,
is that traditional developers,
like professional developers,
not people like me, not random guys like me,
usually they assume that the people
that they're supposed to explain things to
know much more than what they do.
And so they just write a few instructions,
you know, like cryptic instructions
that nobody really understands.
And they would assume that everyone
reading those instructions would understand
what they have to do to,
let's say, use this worker service, for instance.
But that's not the case.
I totally agree.
This portion of Talk Python to Me
is brought to you by Mailtrap,
an email delivery platform that developers love.
An email sending solution with industry-best analytics,
SMTP and email APIs,
SDKs for major programming languages,
and 24-7 human support.
Try for free at mailtrap.io.
You know, it's kind of the curse of knowledge.
Like once you know all of these things,
it's really hard to remember.
Oh, yeah.
So then you just,
oh, just run that in Docker
and then link it and set up a network over there.
You're like, wait a minute.
Yeah.
I don't know how to do that.
I'm just trying to run my Python app.
Like you're bringing a whole new thing in
that you think makes it sound easy
and it makes it sound real hard to me.
I totally agree this is a problem.
So many moving pieces.
When you start coding,
I mean, obviously you know that
because you've been in this game
for much longer than me.
But once you start coding,
there are so many little things
that you have to know to make this thing work.
So it starts with how to just configure GitHub
and connect it to your...
How do you use Git?
If you have a Git conflict,
you might be like,
well, this is done.
I can't do anything else anymore.
It's broken.
Yeah.
I mean, it's really overwhelming
when you're new, right?
There's a lot.
And that's where AI today helps you
because in most cases,
if you know how to talk with the AI,
you will get answers
that are much easier to understand
that what you would have
on Stack Overflow, for instance.
I agree.
It's very interesting how helpful it is.
I think it's a good time
to about jump into that.
But before we do,
tell people about Railway a bit.
How does this work?
I haven't used Railway before.
It's a platform
where you can deploy your apps, basically.
It connects to your GitHub account.
It's not only, I mean,
you have on Railway
not only a possibility
to deploy your Flask app
or other types of apps also,
but they also offer
all the database aspects.
So you can spin a Redis database.
You can have a MySQL database.
I think they also have Mongo.
I mean, they have most of the formats
that you can expect.
And the great thing is that
everything is on the same platform.
Let's say that I've got another project
I'm involved with a developer,
with a real developer,
hi to Alex,
if he listens to this podcast,
a professional developer.
For that project,
for instance,
we have an app on Heroku.
We have a database
on MongoDB Atlas.
And we have the files
uploaded to S3,
to Amazon S3,
for the file storage.
On Railway,
you can,
at least it's what I do,
you can have,
at the same time,
the deployment of the app,
which replaces Heroku.
And you can have the database
also together.
And the cool thing is that
they are,
I would say,
even physically
at the same location.
So in terms of performance,
it's pretty easy to handle.
And it's very user-friendly.
I mean,
very, very easy to use.
From what I saw,
even easier to understand
than Heroku.
And I tried also
some things like Vercel,
or I use for some project also,
but that's more for static website,
Netlify.
But for this time...
Netlify is fantastic for static.
For static,
Netlify is just amazing.
And just the one
where you can just drag and drop
a project,
for instance,
for a static website.
So easy.
But for a more
multi-tenant,
dynamic,
you know,
web app,
like the iJingle Maker,
Railway was really cool.
And as you can see
from the presentation,
it's very user-friendly.
It definitely is.
And the pricing is actually
really decent.
They have a free trial
and then $5 a month.
Yeah.
But that gets you
8 gigs of RAM
and 8 CPUs per service.
That is really good.
I started it
on the OB plan.
And I think that today,
just to give you an idea,
with roughly 500 users
coming to the app per day
and, you know,
a lot of them using the product,
I pay for that
roughly $15 a month.
Incredible.
For both the app deployment
and the database,
which is in MySQL
for RIDI Jingle Maker.
That's pretty impressive.
Good one to know about.
This is cool.
Yes, nice one.
They have good Python support.
Yes, yes.
Very good.
And they have,
as I said,
like most people do today,
a Discord server
monitored also by volunteers.
And there was a guy
the other day,
I didn't even know
he was not part
of the official team
of Railway
and it really helped me.
He wrote some code
for me to make this thing
work with Celery.
So it was really,
really amazing.
And it was on a Sunday
in the evening.
So really nice.
Yeah, that's amazing.
One thing I just want
to give a shout out
to that I came across recently
that's interesting
is Coolify.
Coolify.
Which is,
it's self-hosted
Heroku Netlify
Vercel alternative
and you just get pushed to it.
I don't know
if it's better than this though
because you've got to have
a decent server
to run it on
and you've got to run
the Docker stuff
and whatnot
to sort of do it.
But yeah,
anyway,
speaking of interesting deployments.
Yeah,
you're going to manage also
because the other day,
I think it was 10 days ago,
there was a DDoS attack,
I think,
against Railway
for the European part
of their network.
But they were very quick
jumping on it
and managing all of that
and doing all the mitigation
against it.
If you run your own service,
then you've got to take care
of all of that
on your own,
all the security
and all of that.
There's benefits,
but there's also drawbacks there.
All right,
let's talk about
I think the right way
to start talking about
this,
how you're using AI
and the journey
you went through.
I mean,
we've talked a lot
about foundations already,
but let's talk about your app.
You mentioned a couple of times
AI Jingle Maker.
Tell people what it does.
It's a web app
that you can find
on AI Jingle Maker dot com.
And if you enter the app,
you can create
your own sweepers,
radio jingles,
podcast intros,
audio promos,
as if you were
playing with Lego bricks,
I would say.
It's not the usual
to experience.
Like,
if you'll be using things
like GarageBand
or FL Studio
or Pro Tools
to edit your audio,
you can imagine
those waves
that you've got
to move around
to create
your jingles
or your sweepers.
If you're using,
for instance,
the open source
Audacity software
also on your computer,
you can do that.
But still,
you've got to know
how to move
these things around
and how to play
with the volume,
the fade in,
the fade out,
the reverb,
the chorus,
the flanger,
I mean,
all the effects.
And I mean,
it's not that easy
for many people.
And so I thought
that I could build
something that
made it as easy
as pressing
on a few buttons.
that's the idea
of the product.
So the way
you use it
when you enter
the product,
you've got
four different parts.
You've got
the intro,
the background,
the outro,
and the voiceover,
which is on top
of the background.
And the voiceover,
you've got,
now you've got
three different options.
You've got
the possibility
to record
your own voice.
So I rebuilt
a voice recorder,
an online voice recorder,
where you can
quickly record
your voice,
add a few effects,
and then,
boom,
use that
as your voiceover.
You can also
upload an existing
recording that you
have on your computer.
So if you've got
something that you
recorded with your,
with FL Studio
or something else,
you can upload it
and use it
as a voiceover.
Or you can use AI.
So I'm connected
to a bunch
of text-to-speech APIs.
So I didn't develop
the models myself.
I'm not someone
smart enough
to develop
a foundational model,
but I'm connected
to the APIs.
and you can
pick one of the voices.
You can write your text,
generate the voiceover,
and once you have
the voiceover,
you just select it.
And when you have
the voiceover,
you choose a background
behind it.
So let's say groovy music,
house music,
rock music,
romantic music,
whatever.
You've got
some pre-made
sounds in the app.
You choose an intro,
an outro,
and then you press
on generate jingle.
and in five seconds,
you've got the jingle.
That's basically,
that's basically the idea.
I'll put in the jingle
so people will know
exactly what this sounds.
Yeah,
I'll put it in right now.
Party time!
This is Martin Superstar,
your number one favorite DJ
in New York City.
It's really cool
and it's something
that I've seen people
hire voiceover actors
on,
like Fiverr
and stuff like that.
They'll maybe
pay 30 bucks
to have somebody
do a couple of trials
and throw some music
on top of
or something like that,
right?
And I'm a voiceover artist
on Fiverr.
I'm doing that also.
So I know exactly
what it is.
Let me see if I can
automate my job away.
It was not really
the idea of automating
completely a job away.
It was more like
the,
how can you create
something that's self-service
and that can meet
the needs of people,
as you said,
who don't want to spend
50, 50 bucks
or 100 bucks
for something,
but who want to have
an easy way
to create
basic sweepers,
jingles
or some other things.
And the first target
was mostly
indie radio stations
or small podcasts.
But then I saw
many brands
coming,
like,
I wouldn't say,
not the big brands,
but small brands
coming,
like apparel brands
or coffee shops
or I had,
the other day,
a bar in Ibiza
signing up
and paying for credits
to generate
a promo
for the bar
in Ibiza.
So,
yeah,
it's not only
radio stations
and podcasts,
it's also anyone
who wants to create
a promo
for their business.
So that's also
one of the services.
when I started,
it was only
short sweepers,
jingles,
radio station,
ideas,
stuff like that.
But then I added
something which is
called the promo maker,
which you have
in the jingle maker,
where you can create
something which is
up to 30 seconds long.
So more like a radio ad.
That's another.
And there,
you can also use AI.
It's connected to open AI,
to be honest,
but you can also use AI
to generate the text
of your promo.
So just put the name
of your business,
what you're selling,
your service,
your product.
Then it will suggest
the text.
Then you choose
the voice,
generate the AI voice,
and then you add the sounds
and then it's finished.
So let's say in 20 seconds,
you've got a node you add.
So that's the promise
for the promo maker.
It's a cool app
and it's really impressive
to look at this
and think that
you built this
with less than a year
of Python
or really any coding
experience, right?
Roughly that amount?
To put things
really in perspective
so that people know
what they can expect
if they start
their coding journey.
So I started
coding in Python
in September,
September,
October,
2022.
For a few months,
as I said,
I was mostly coding
scripts on my computer
that helped me
in my daily business
because I didn't tell you
in the beginning,
but most of my activity
is online marketing.
It's working for startups
and bigger companies also.
I need scripts
for competitive intelligence,
for SEO,
or for even content production,
this type of thing.
So I created a lot
of scripts locally
on my computer
before considering
the front-end part.
Then that's when
I discovered Flask.
That was just before
the summer of 2023.
And yes,
the first version
of the iJingle maker
that I launched,
it was just
on the home page.
You couldn't
basically
tweak anything.
There were
just four different
jingles
and just put the name
of your radio station.
You press on generate
and it generated
one thing,
the same for everyone.
And I started
getting some traction
between May 2023
and August.
And then I said,
okay,
I'm going to really
dive into this project
and develop something
more sophisticated.
I started working
on that
on a Monday
in September
and it was released
on the Friday,
the V2.
And I got to tell you,
your website now
looks really nice.
You've done a lot
of good design work
on it as well
in the last couple
of months.
Yeah,
it has evolved
because maybe you saw
it for the first time
when we decided
to do this podcast
and it was a white page.
The logo was the same,
but it was different.
Originally,
it was only in material design.
I was using material design
via the CDN
from Google.
But then I wanted
to use Tailwind.
The new version
that you see
is using Tailwind
so people might recognize
the Tailwind vibe.
And I worked quite a lot
on this thing that,
okay,
we said it's audio
so people don't see it.
But if you go on the website,
you will see it.
There is this rotating list
of things
that you can create
with the product.
it was inspired
by some code
that I found
but I had to retweak it
for, you know,
make it responsive
and all of that.
And you know,
also a big shout out
to my son
who is 18
who is learning Python
a lot.
He coded
a few things recently.
He's coding
something to play darts
at the moment,
like to calculate
the scores in darts.
And two months ago,
he said to me
that your side
is nice
but it looks ugly.
so could you make
something that looks
better?
I said,
yeah,
but you know,
I kind of like it.
I said,
no,
that.
It's not the way
it should be.
So do something better.
I know you can do it.
So that's why also
we've got something
which looks better today
thanks to my son,
Maxim.
It's a huge improvement
from where it started.
So nice work on that.
Yeah.
All right,
let's talk about
some of the techniques
that you used here to,
first of all,
what LLM did you use
to go on this journey?
When I started,
I wasn't even aware
of GitHub Copilot.
So I started only
with ChatGPT.
I was an early
premium user
of ChatGPT.
so I started paying
the 20 bucks
very,
very early
for GPT Plus.
So I started using
ChatGPT.
So basically switching
between
the ChatGPT UI
and the IDE.
I started using
PyCharm.
So that's the first one
I used.
So I was creating
some code
in ChatGPT
and then jumping
to PyCharm,
test the code,
and then if there was a bug,
coming back to ChatGPT.
So this back and forth journey.
You asked it
at the beginning,
how do I make a flask
app or what did you ask
it in the beginning?
Like, how do I make
a flask app?
How do I make a flask app
that does audio?
Like, what did you?
I knew that I wanted
to use flask.
So the first thing
that you would ask
is to ask ChatGPT
for a boilerplate
of a flask web app.
And it will give you
pretty quickly
the basic building blocks.
I don't know
if it would give you
straight away
the architecture
with a template
inside of the
templates folder,
but, you know,
it gives you
here.
Hello world.
Yeah,
hello world on the page.
But then,
if you know
that you need
HTML,
then you will ask
ChatGPT
to tweak it
to render
index.html
from the templates folder.
And there you see,
there it starts
and it gives you
some boilerplate
for the HTML
that you put
in the templates folder.
and then you learn
that you need
ideally to have
some JavaScript
in a JavaScript file
and that you need
some CSS
in a CSS file
and that those two files
will be in the
static folder
of a flask web app.
So now I've got,
let's say,
my routine,
I've got all of that
ready
and if I start
a new app,
I don't even need
obviously ChatGPT.
I just create
my structure.
I put index.html,
script.js,
styles.css.
But then,
what you can also ask
ChatGPT to do,
for instance,
is if you've got
your HTML page,
you can say,
restyle this HTML page
with Tailwind CSS
using the CDN,
for instance,
and it will give you
a full restyling.
And then you can ask it,
okay,
I want on this page
four buttons
and those four buttons
should do XYZ
and then you start
moving into
the JavaScript
part of it
for the interactions
on the page.
The interesting thing
maybe,
which would explain
also why
I haven't really
started using
Next.js
or Vue.js
or things like that,
is that by default,
for some reason,
you've got to ask
OpenAI why,
maybe because of
some legacy
importance of
Vaniya JavaScript,
but if you ask
ChatGPT
to start
creating some
interactions
on an HTML page,
it won't just
tell you,
okay,
you know,
these days people
use React
or Next.js
or something like that,
so maybe you could
or you should
consider that.
It will go deep
into Vaniya JavaScript.
And after
developing
the Jingle Maker
for a few months,
I showed it to
my friend Alex,
who is this developer
I was talking about
earlier,
who has graduated,
I would say,
from Vaniya JavaScript
to React,
and he looked
at my code and said,
man,
that's crazy.
It's all
Vaniya JavaScript.
There's not a single
line of React.
So everything
in your app
is lines and lines
and lines of JavaScript.
That's a benefit
and a drawback.
He said that
he would not
even be able
to write it
this way
from scratch
today.
Yeah, yeah.
That's not something
that he would
really consider doing
because it's
more verbose.
There's more stuff
to write
to achieve
what you want
to achieve.
But the thing
is that
with ChatGPT
or today
with a
GitHub Copilot
embedded in
the IDE,
even if it's longer,
that's not a problem
because you don't
write a single
line of code.
I think it's important
to point that out
is that
in the
Jingle Maker,
there is not
one single
line of code
that I wrote.
Not one.
That's insane.
There's not one.
Not a single
line of code
that I typed
from the first
curly bracket
to the last
curly bracket.
Nothing.
Everything is
written like that.
Yesterday, for instance,
I was working on
something completely
different now
for a friend
who is also a client
who is working
on a Gmail add-on.
So I don't know
if you're familiar
with that,
but you're using
Apps Script
from Google
and then
create a manifest
and blah, blah.
And I didn't know
anything
about Gmail add-ons
until yesterday
in the morning.
And after
now five hours
of work,
we've got a fully
working product
in Gmail.
That's amazing.
That's crazy.
2024.
And it's only
the beginning.
I really see
that evolving
super fast.
I think that
now the most
important thing
is to be able
to talk to the machine,
to explain
the structure,
the architecture
of what you expect
and to be clear
in your head
about
the code
has to be
developed
for the pages
to interact,
for the elements
to interact together.
And if it's clear
in your head
and if you can
explain it clearly
to the LLM,
it's just magic.
It is like magic.
Yeah.
It's pretty wild.
If you're a regular
listener of the podcast,
you surely heard
about Talk Python's
online courses.
But have you had
a chance to try them out?
No matter the level
you're looking for,
we have a course for you.
Our Python for Absolute Beginners
is like an introduction
to Python
plus that first year
computer science course
that you never took.
Our data-driven
web app courses
build a full
PyPI.org clone
along with you
right on the screen.
And we even have
a few courses
to dip your toe in with.
See what we have to offer
at training.talkpython.fm
or just click the link
in your podcast player.
So you can see
on the side here
I have these really weird
recent chats I had
like a skilled
baker Q&A
and survive a plane crash
in the wilderness.
And so these things
are actually related.
And what I was trying to do
was I was trying to
understand how
much prompt engineering
and sort of setting
the stage
for the questions
matters.
So like this one,
I said,
you are a very skilled
baker.
You have run
a successful restaurant
in the city
for five years.
Now I will ask you
questions
as opposed to
this one.
You are a very skilled
outdoorsman
and you've been
on multiple reality shows.
Now I'll ask you
some questions.
And they were both
the same question.
If I'm in a plane crash
and I need to survive,
I wanted to see
how much
like the baker
would focus on
food
and stuff
versus the survivalist
on others.
and I feel
like that's
a real clear
way to understand
this kind
of stuff
in just
a real general
way.
But I think
there must be
a code
aspect of that
as well.
Like rather
than just
tell me how
to do this
in Python,
like you
have written
this app
in Python
or you're
an expert
on Fast
API,
now I want
to talk
to you,
you may
get different
results,
maybe better,
maybe worse,
I don't know.
But did you
try any
of this
techniques
or was it
just straight
down the middle?
Tell me how
to do this
with Tailwind.
To be fair
with you,
because I was
a total
newbie
in the beginning,
I was making
sure to ask
the AI
to explain
to me
almost as
if I were
a five-year-old.
You know?
Yeah.
Because I could
have told
the AI,
you're an
expert
Python
developer
and then
just give
me the
code.
But then
I don't
have all
the
explanations
because
then
it
behaves
like
an
expert
Python
developer
and
there
are
many
shortcuts
that
it
will
take
and
not
really
give
you
all
the
details
documenting
all
the
code.
So
I'm
still
more like
in
explain
to me
in layman's
terms
how to
do
this
because
then
also
I
understand
the
code
so
it's
easier
for me
to
debug
it
I
usually
take
the
analogy
that
when
you
said
that
sometimes
you
think
it
might
be
too late
to learn
to code
or to learn
to do
something
let's say
that you
want to learn
to play
music
the piano
at a certain
age
it becomes
very
difficult
because
you don't
have
the
reflex
muscles
agility
that
you
can
have
when
you
are
a
young
kid
to
learn
how
to
play
the
piano
but
still
you
could
understand
what's
on the
score
written
on the
page
from
the
music
so
encoding
for me
it's
kind
of
the
same
I
would
to be
honest
with
you
I
would
not
be
able
to
write
most
of
the
code
that
is
in
my
app
myself
but
I
can
read
the
score
connections
between
the
different
building
blocks
in
the
code
so
I
can
understand
if
there
is
a
problem
syntax
issue
because
there's
some
closing
brackets
I can't
see
it
I
wouldn't
be able
to
write
the
code
properly
in the
first
place
myself
you
could
argue
it's
a
problem
output
is
what
matters
it's
the
final
product
which
is
what
matters
so
as
long
I
understand
what's
on
the
screen
for
me
it's
okay
yeah
well
let's
loop
it
back
to
the
original
way
we
started
this
one
way
you
could
do
this
is
you
could
hire
people
to
build
this
for
you
and
give
you
the
code
and
you're
in
the
same
position
like
here's
a
huge
pile
of
code
and
you
probably
understand
it
I'm
sure
you
understand
it
less
well
than
if
you
went
through
step
by
100%
sure
I
was
in
that
position
a
few
times
where
I
was
involved
in
some
projects
and
I
was
not
involved
in
the
actual
coding
of
the
project
and
then
I
inherited
the
project
I
had
the
code
base
but
I
could
put
it
on
a
shelf
because
I
would
not
be
able
to
do
anything
with
that
whereas
now
I
understand
every
single
section
of
what's
written
moment
I'm
repurposing
some
of
the
payment
logic
because
I
will
switch
from
stripe
to
paddle
in
the
iJingle
maker
and
yeah
so
I've
got
to
rebuild
the
payment
models
I've
got
to
rebuild
the
flask
route
for
the
API
endpoints
for
the
payment
confirmations
and
all
of
that
so
I
know
where
they
are
and
I
know
how
to
tweak
them
and
I
can
highlight
exactly
what
I
want
and
now
I'm
using
I
would
say
75%
of
the
time
I'm
using
github
copilot
straight
in
the
IDE
directly
because
it's
in
context
then
you
highlight
the
code
and
you
then
if
the
suggestion
is
nice
you
just
insert
it
to
replace
the
code
so
yeah
once
you've
got
something
that
you
understand
it
goes
faster
and
yeah
you're
still
early
in
this
project
right
this
is
yeah
super
early
five
six
months
or
something
like
a
baby
yes
I
imagine
as
you
do
more
of
this
you
might
not
choose
to
write
a lot
of
code
but
I
bet
you'll
start
to be
able
to
write
code
kind
of
like
language
immersion
you know
if you
move
to
Brazil
you
would
start
to
learn
Portuguese
yes
eventually
just
because
you're
in
that
environment
so
much
you
know
but
sometimes
really
you
know
with
the
suggestions
it's
you
wouldn't
see
why
you
would
write
the
code
for
instance
I
had
earlier
today
I
was
creating
a
scraper
to
check
the
technology
used
by
different
websites
by
looking
in
the
source
code
for
let's
say
WP
for
WordPress
Odoo
for Odoo
Squarespace
Weebly
you know
this kind
of thing
we just
wrote
together
with
the
first
part
and
then
we
had
to
replicate
the
code
in
beautiful
soup
for
the
scraper
for
each
of
them
there's
absolutely
no
reason
why
I
would
write
each
iteration
and
once
you
write
two
of
them
then
you
with
copilot
you
just
go
with
your
tab
to
the
next
section
and
you
understand
what
you
expect
because
you
have
three
or
four
technologies
that
you
want
to
track
in
your
code
that
you
declared
before
they
will
have
to
write
a
block
of
six
lines
boom
that's
the
block
of
six
lines
there's
no
reason
in
the
world
why
I
would
write
those
six
lines
you
know
amazing
that's
crazy
one more
prompt
engineering
thing
you talked
about
and I
think
it is
a
problem
so
I
asked
basically
what's
the
boilerplate
and
it
said
boom
here's
the
boilerplate
for
flask
and
chat
GPT
then
I
said
well
template
and
it
said
boom
here's
the
two
pieces
of
code
you
said
sometimes
this
can
be
really
challenging
you
said
one
of
the
techniques
used
was
to
explain
me
like
a
five
year old
another
thing
that
works
really
well
is
I
just
said
tell
me
this
again
let's
think
step
by
and
it
gave
me
a
step
process
start
one
install
flask
create
a
project
directory
create
the
project
script
import
flask
and
it
was
really
much
more
like
this
is
what
each
step
you
need
to
do
when
you
start
learning
it's
nice
to
do
it
step
by
because
some
people
don't
understand
and
that's
quite
normal
simple
things
like
that
so
in
the
beginning
it's
nice
to
go
step
by
it's
really
powerful
and
it's
something
people
can
check
out
there's
a
cool
video
prompt
engineering
by
Patrick
Lovier
has
a
bunch
of
advice
from
places
like
Anthropic
and
others
here
some
things
you
can
try
it's
also
evolving
thanks
also
to
the
longer
context
windows
that
we
have
today
in
the
LLM
because
when
I
started
doing
that
in
the
context
window
was
maximum
tokens
or
something
like
that
so
you
had
to
really
go
by
short
section
it
was
very
difficult
to
debug
long
pieces
of
code
long
sections
of
code
now
the
token
window
is
128,000
on
open
AI
and
even
longer
on
cloud
or
other
LLMs
today
it's
possible
to
basically
throw
at some
point
lines
of code
in
or
and get
refactoring
debugging
that's
also
really
amazing
when
you
need
let's
say
you
know
that
you
created
something
cool
in
one
app
some
business
logic
something
interesting
but
you
know
that
you
want
to
just
repurpose
it
in
a
small
way
like
make
little
tweaks
you
just
throw
all
the
code
into
the
LLM
and
you
just
explain
the
little
changes
that
you
want
and
it
will
give
you
the
adapted
code
fully
functional
in
one
go
shot
which
is
also
impressive
that
is
super
impressive
so
it
sounds
like
you
use
google
copilot
a lot
have
you
looked
at
gpt
engineer
no
so
i
haven't
really
either
but
it
basically
it's
supposed
to be
kind
of
an
iterative
thing
that
goes
it
will
generate
all
the
multiple
files
understand
how
all
those
pieces
fit
together
and
work
so
more
like
an
agent
logic
yeah
exactly
so
but
pretty
i
started
working
with
the
gpt
from
open
ai
from
chat
gpt
i
created
a few
of
them
it
was
a
funny
one
for
instance
i'm
working
for
an
accounting
firm
for
some
marketing
and
the
boss
of
the
company
sent
me
a
document
of
pages
explaining
the
accounting
module
on
Odoo
which
is
an
erp
system
two
weeks
ago
and
he
said
oh
you
should
read
that
to
be
able
to
understand
it
and
answer
questions
about
the
module
and
i
just
threw
it
into
chat
gpt
uploaded
the
pdf
and
i
created
a
custom
custom
gpt
questions
about
the
accounting
module
so
that's
insane
instead
of
reading
the
and
also
another
nice
use
case
that
i
have
it's
nothing
about
coding
but
sometimes
you're
just
on
youtube
and
someone
tells
you
this
is
the
five
big
important
things
you have
to
know
in
which
would
change
your
life
forever
so
i'm
tempted
maybe
i will
watch
this
video
because
it
might
be
interesting
but
i
say
no
it's
probably
not
that
interesting
it's
probably
a lot
of
fluff
so
now
usually
what
i do
is
that
i
i've
got
a
website
called
i don't
remember
the name
sorry
but
one
of
the
websites
where
you
can
get
the
transcript
of
a
video
transcript
throw
it
into
chat
gpt
and
then
i
ask
what
are
the
five
important
things
i
should
know
that
would
change
my
life
forever
and
then
i've
got
them
in
five
seconds
i don't
want
to
i don't
need
to watch
a 35
minutes
video
and
maybe
decide
to watch
it
later
right
yeah
awesome
what an
interesting
story
fred
i think
maybe
we
should
wrap
it
up
but
people
can
check
out
ai
jingle
maker
there's
two
other
things
from
you
that
are
noteworthy
one
is
you
have
your
ai
coding
club
newsletter
do you
want to
tell
people
about
that
yeah
that's
a
newsletter
i
started
which
is
connected
to
some
of
the
videos
i
posted
on
youtube
where
i
explain
to
people
coding
purposes
i
will
start
sending
the
newsletters
soon
actually
i
started
registering
people
but
i
haven't
sent
the
first
edition
yet
but
we'll
start
very
soon
i've
got
also
a
new
app
coming
up
probably
within
two
weeks
it
will
be
called
the
ai
show
maker
it's
a
way
to
create
a
podcast
or
a
radio
show
with
building
blogs
so
it's
the
same
concept
as
the
jingle
maker
but
for
longer
form
that
sounds
really
interesting
yeah
all right
cool
people
can
check
it
out
here
and
by
the way
i've
been
thinking
a lot
about
email
and
newsletters
and stuff
i was
doing a
bunch
with
mailchimp
for
many
years
and
it's
just
got
to be
super
expensive
and
i got
frustrated
with
them
so
did
a
bunch
of
research
on
different
platforms
looked
at
button
down
dot
email
and
actually
chose
list
monk
which
is
self
hosted
and
docker
style
thing
but
one
of
the
ones
that
i
came
across
at
the
end
is
beehive
which
looks
pretty
interesting
are
you
happy
with
beehive
it's
more
competing
with
sub
stack
i think
it was
co-created
by one
of the
guys
who
co-founded
morning
brew
the newsletter
morning
brew
so
he knows
what
he's
talking
about
and
it's
really
also
well
executed
it's
a
pleasure
free
up
to
subscribers
yeah
that's
the pricing
is way
way
better
than
things
like
mailchimp
and stuff
so
it's
nice
also
cheaper
than
sub stack
so they
don't
i don't
know
which
cut
they
take
from
the
subscription
if you
run a
premium
newsletter
but it's
much
cheaper
than
a
sub
stack
i think
sub
stack
takes
10%
from
like
patreon
and
other
platforms
like
that
nice
all
right
and
then
one
other
thing
is
your
call me
Fred
youtube
channel
yeah
i've
got
some
videos
there
some
of
the
videos
are
explaining
how to
use
the
jingle
maker
the
recent
ones
but also
some
of
them
are
about
this
journey
of
how
to
code
with
AI
there
are
some
concrete
examples
also
like
i coded
recently
a
Chrome
extension
a
bookmarking
Chrome
extension
all
the
code
explanations
is
on
YouTube
and
the
code
on
GitHub
so
i've
got
different
projects
like
that
and
i'm
usually
documenting
what i
do
on
YouTube
yeah
nice
so
people
can
check
that
out
all
right
well
i
think
that
about
does
it
for
the
time
that
we
got
together
but
thanks
for
coming
on
and
sharing
your
story
i think
it'll
inspire
a lot
of
folks
thank
you
i hope
that
everything
was
clear
i wasn't
cursed
to be
too cryptic
like the
developers
i was
talking
about
but
yeah
so
it's
really
exciting
it's
rejuvenating
as you
could say
it's
opening up
a whole
world
of
possibilities
right
i wish
i would
have
started
earlier
to be
honest
because
when i
see my
son
he's
and
what
he
you
know
what
he
already
does
today
with
python
that's
quite
amazing
so
when
you're
imagine
where
you
will
be
when
you
will
be
or
it
would
be
like
really
good
so
yeah
that's
the
beauty
that's
the
beauty
of
it
so
don't
wait
too
long
if
you're
young
if
you're
listening
to
the
podcast
start
today
or
yesterday
even
yeah
it's
amazing
awesome
well
totally
agree
thanks so
much
for being
here
and
see you
later
thank you
so much
bye
this has
been another
episode of
talk python
to me
thank you
to our
sponsors
be sure
to check
out what
they're
offering
it
really
helps
support
the
show
mail
Mailtrap
an
email
delivery
platform
that
developers
love
try
for
free
at
mail
trap
dot
i
want to
level up
your
python
we have
one of
the
largest
catalogs
of
python
video
courses
over
at
talk
python
our
content
ranges
from
true
beginners
to
deeply
advanced
topics
like
memory
and
async
best
of
all
there's
not
a
subscription
in
sight
check
it
out
for
yourself
at
training
talk
python
dot
fm
be
sure
to
subscribe
the
show
open
your
favorite
podcast
app
and
search
for
python
we
should
be
right
also
find
the
itunes
feed
at
slash
itunes
the google
play
feed
at
slash
play
and
the
direct
rss
feed
at
slash
rss
on
talk
python
dot
fm
we're
live
streaming
most
of
our
recordings
these
days
if
you
want
to
be
part
of
the
show
and
have
your
comments
featured
on
the
air
be
sure
to
subscribe
our
youtube
channel
at
talk
python
dot
fm
slash
youtube
this
is
your
host
michael
kennedy
thanks
so
much
for
listening
i
really
appreciate
it
now
get
out
there
and
write
some
python
code
you
have
a
Bye.
you
Thank you.